you know we gotta talk about canna  reeves he's my favorite he revealed  something um i don't think any of us  were expecting  yes during an appearance on red table  talk keanu looked back at some of his  favorite halloween costumes  and recalled dressing up as dolly parton  as a playboy bunny i think i love this  anyway get this piano's mom accidentally  designed dolly's iconic outfit take a  look and we'll see you tomorrow bye guys  hi so my mother was a costume designer  and she made some costumes for dolly  parton and she once did the cover of  playboy right and somehow i guess she  didn't take that home  and so we had him and it was  halloween so i put on the ears and the  boucier  i wore sneakers with fishnet stockings  in the bow tie  yeah key come on i had some pretty long  hair and i was dolly parton's playboy  bunny ah oh amazing